c'est ce quiz et je vous accorde à la
voilà c'est parti alors je suis celle
qui est aux commandes du lutin c'est
[ __ ] de lumière du bronze et je pense
que ça risque d'être drôle alors atteint
on va mettre comme un peu de son parce
que sinon il ya du sommet éteint la
lumière mais et toi cette lumière
battant déjà joué avec salah non plus
tôt voilà et maintenant tu tournes la
souris et tu vas dans les cellules et
éclaire un peu là où tu as besoin de
voir si une photo non croyants dans les
toilettes dans l'évier éventuellement
non non il ya un couloir à gauche mais
tu vas pas faire une crise cardiaque
tout de suite ça vous prenez grand mot
enfin je veux dire moi jamais j'ai
failli frôler la crise cardiaque dans un
scanner jamais la première question que
je me demande c'est pourquoi il ya des
murs cassé dans le président s'est enfin
battu teva diamants ne tarde pas à
casser un mur bien honnêtement
enfin moi que tu t'appelles hulk ou quoi
moi tu peut être pas trois mais en fait
je regarde même pas si elle est faisant
ouais bah tu sais quoi je te le dirais
alors vas-y avance je sens que tu vas tu
tombes situées aux éléments pratiques
vas-y va obliger la y en a eu une
nouvelle attend cherche alors à tant
d'autres côté regarde bien non il n'y a
pas de photo la voix les noms des trois
quilles et tu vas pas tu vas pas mourir
tu restes avec nous un bon allez
continuez continuez à sa non sais c'est
quoi ça c'est dû à c'est du chinois bon
tu des chiffres le assez glauque [ __ ]
à puceul chine on est retourné d'y
retourner retour si non c'est toi excuse
moi c'est bon c'est bon j'arrête retombe
pas de celui non aux quais bas coûts
mais cours il faut trouver une photo
mais oui mais je suis prêt donc et
barrettes de shit
je me suis dessus c'est que les photos
étant cette [ __ ] de membres mais tu es
aimé des mimines
et voilà tu as et puis c'est quoi la
touche pour elle mais l'un dans des
genres avec les atteintes à temps je
m'attendais temps obligé doit y avoir
une photo là en fait tu tournes en rond
depuis tout à l'heure parce que tu chip
sud-vendée endroits de merde et un mois
la lumière baissée mais regard tu
reprends le même chemin mais c'est
inadmissible vasile va tout droit
vas-y tu es tu fais exactement suis bon
je m'en fous je fais ce que je te dise
non tu prends un os poing dans la gueule
gauche
vas-y avance bien et tu vas pas vomir
ensuite là tu vas aller à gauche d'un
coup tu vas bintje tag t'as pas peur
voilà avant maintenant regarde ma
cellule à droite voilà continues tu
prends le mur cassée par un prisonnier
plutôt vénère reviendra sur les côtés
des sapeurs regarde pas toi c'est comme
quand tu enlèves tuera pas le vide
maintenant vous trouvez des [ __ ] de
photos je suis sûr qu'on nous paye c'est
pas possible on devrait logiquement va
t'en as pas facile vas-y pourquoi tu as
eu peur un mégot est basique mais non l
es tu déconnes vrai roman faut courir
faut se balader tranquillement revient
rien mais le regarde y'a quoi y'a rien à
4,6 à ben voilà là on est vers le chemin
de la sortie
une photo la première ok j'ai pu passer
une photo
je t'aime
il nous a pris position foetale
il va aller position foetale plus au
sérieux il est quoi le foyer cause de
quoi
pour les gens à l'inversé de place parce
que cette fan children trouillarde alors
par contre du coup là tu es copilote
intérêt à me dire où se trouve j'étais
sûr cannavino si certains de bing on
pourra mettre d'accord ok donc faut
trouver les photos noir mais pas dans le
four mais tu sais pas déjà y être
occident mais si tu peux pas dans le
fond mais qui tu parles de ce principe
ne met pas la lumière
ok ce que je veux voir où je n'en mets
truc c'est que j'allume pour bien
trouver les photos si on a en fait non
je ne cherche pas d'excusés mais et
éclats les baies stender effet que tu as
failli mourir de peur vous droits légaux
non franchement faut vraiment se marche
un an à pékin mais c'est exact moi
j'aurais aimé y croire mais c'est quoi
cette l'homme qui l'a dit c'est le mec
il gérait une pièce de deux euros tu
sais que mes cmed chez les petites
emplettes faut un petit temps plein
c'est avec la pâte tout un couloir
madame dont je le dis bref faut beaucoup
source sur le coup mais il n'a que 8 ans
un truc mais arrête avec tes dents quand
je vais voir jouer si elle je voulais
mais j'avais très mal mais je m'étais
jerry comme [ __ ] nez comme groupon me
sentais vraiment
imaginez là ça va être chaud parce qu'il
va nous tuer direct j'arrive à faire
heureuse d'une coûteuse balayette
à bientôt des biens mais je me terne et
un essai un truc de ouf j'arrive pas
unie à bien me retrouver dans sept
länder là autant dans les autres je suis
mort de peur donc j'arrive pas autant là
franchement j'ai pas spécialement peur
on est déjà à enfin de nouvelles têtes
j'arrête qu'ai-je donc jamais ça non
mais serait-il trop bien mais je veux
juste une photo de toi qui n'a trouvé
tutélaire même et je me retrouve pas et
c'est une prison trop chelou aussi des
murs péter il ya des remèdes déclaré
qu'une paire à bergeron en plus il a un
gong sais pas pourquoi il a un bon c'est
un chien quoi attends attends puis celle
des boeufs et drôle à la grc j'aime pas
quand il ya plein de l'urp été de suite
comme ça allez ici
ici on aurait à oui il y en a une année
une année j'ai juste pris de photo cl
oui là-bas c'est bien noir métal jaune a
ramassé une et j'avoue lui a été
attaquée parce qu'on a mis quatre ans à
la trouver ce2 à la jumelle a dit oui
mais c'est un vieux m'a aidé moi juste
et c'est ont fait les la gauche droite
il apparaît comme ça cette dernière fois
bon on nous a collé q
là c'est urgent bon faut vraiment voir
par oh la la
pourquoi rester convoyage on commence
par là et on va vraiment faire genre le
le tour de l'amérique et de queen est
belle mais c'est que la première photo
mais vraiment beaucoup de temps à la
trouver enfin je pensais mais ça vient
vraiment de là tu vois je remettrai pas
le messie dans le monde paris voyait
trois quatre ans j'ai pas les jeunes en
fait j'aime pas le bourhis formation oui
bah oui je veux juste me promener dans
une prison sans aucun but avait
d'ailleurs péter est un employé qui n'a
pas de visage qui veut me violer
ça te rassure merde
et c'est quoi ce slider tchité la [ __ ]
ici je suis sûre qu'elle photo là mais
c'est pas possible mais sonic 3 kg va
crier radars photo s'il vous plaît
c'est bon la renommée a qu'une
on l'a trouvée direct tu vas pas balayer
il va pas apparaître la ligue il est bon
et ce n'est pas l'un des états et c'est
franchement on le vend lui fait-on
ducasse le détenu que là tu vois bien
tout est balayé qu'il s'assure via les
réserves ou de tous et ivoire aurait
voté pour pas celui de travers parce que
mec en partance et tu pourras m li
traverse un peu plus long terme
oui si on bat la non madame vers ici tu
viens ici comme une semaine il va nous
indiquer par écrit
we just under tiens je dois y est pour
toi
il est pour toi pour ton visage tout
blanc c'est pourquoi red deux pas du
tout oh [ __ ] mais là je sais pas et ça
c'est que nous empêchait pas défaussés
cdd ce qui en fait tu passes ta mère je
sais pas moi mais pour que ça fait ça
que je sais pas vous mais je sais je
sais pas et pourquoi ça fait sale un
gecko quitto bleu si je recommence à la
tortue il est reproché par le chinois tu
vois cette photo là
allez paraguay en tête préfèrent un
symbole eh oui bah oui bon bah oui bah
oui oui mais je les écris sur bleu ça
veut dire quelque chose est sûre c'est
un truc subliminal ou quoi mais c'est
impossible
ah là là là tu vois l'application là je
sens que viennent
hyseni a tous si elle risque en tout cas
ça lag laub est le fps la haye à
l'échelle via les chaînes mais elle boit
ne sont vraiment pas trop en plus je
suis sûr dans les commentaires ouais a
tellement il y avait une faute ou
voulaient pas bientôt il ya une foule
est pas lui faisait du deuxième sous sol
est nul
tu es nul moi je joue déjà à moi je
porte mes couilles
voilà comme comme préciser les choses
avancent c'est bon sur cette matière
mais [ __ ] mais non mais non mais c'est
pas vrai je suis sur le en fait le mec a
créé jeu c'est un gros mytho
il a mis deux photos et l'a fait trop
mal bonne chance à tous les amis ça
donne envie de cartons sneijder van
celui-là n'était pas d'accord gentil
avions les gars me commettre leur tout
moche c'est bon on va essayer un autre
jour vous à nous faille à notre mission